[Music]
welcome and thank you for joining us at
team intel paneers for our advancing
healthcare webinar series
my name is dr derrick lenz and i will be
your moderator today i serve as
marketing manager for plasma proteins at
siemens health and ears
i would like to introduce
our subject matter expert and the
content of this webinar titled
evaluating mguts
monoclonal gammopathies of undetermined
significance
with free light chain in clinical
practice
our speaker today dr john mitios
graduated with a phd in chemistry from
the university of ioannina
in greece
followed by a postdoctoral fellowship at
the university of california in san
diego
as well as a clinical chemistry
fellowship at washington university in
st louis missouri
john has had many research interests
over the years but he has primarily
focused throughout his education and
training on coagulation with an emphasis
on platelet function in biology
additional experiences for dr mitsios
include faculty at weill cornell
university as an assistant professor of
pathology and laboratory medicine
as well as an attending
assistant clinical chemist at new york
presbyterian hospital
he served as assistant director of the
special coagulation laboratory at
bioreference laboratories and he
currently serves here at siemens health
veneers as a clinical consultant on
scientific and clinical affairs
he has well published having co-authored
20 peer-reviewed journals and three book
chapters
please join me in welcoming
dr john mitchios to the presentation
dr mitsios the floor is all yours
thank you doctor
thank you dr lens for that introduction
so today we're going to
learn here our learning objective for
today's talk so we're going to define
multiple myeloma and monochromal
gammopathy of undetermined significance
or mgus
we're going to describe the clinical
criteria used to define multiple myeloma
as well as describe the use of free
light chain
in the evaluation of mgus
we know in the bone marrow there are a
number of cells that are produced for
example white blood cells such as plasma
cells b cells t cells and natural killer
cells
all help in fighting off an infection in
addition we have red blood cells which
their primary function is to carry
oxygen to the tissues
in addition we have various hemostasis
uh
molecule cells like platelets will help
which help in the coagulation process
but interestingly in the context of
multiple myeloma what we end up having
have happened is an overproduction of
these plants in the cells in which
essentially the process goes haywire
producing an abnormal amount of plasma
cells
plasma cells make antibodies which help
fight off infection by recognizing or
attaching to bacteria and viruses i
always like to equate an antibiotic to
that of a post-it posted in which it
tags the virus or the bacteria and
targets it for destruction
now these immunoglobulin molecules are
made up of two identical light genes
together with two identical heavy genes
the type of heavy chain determines the
immunoglobulin class such as an iga an
igg
ige an igg or an ign
now each specific plasma cell only
produces one specific antibody resulting
in one specific heavy chain and one
specific light chain as shown in the
slide
however there's a slight overproduction
of light genes which can be detected
circulating in their free form that is
not bound to the heavy changes in plasma
these are called light genes
multiple myeloma leads to an
overproduction of plasma cells resulting
in monochromal gammopathy that is an
overproduction of these immunoglobulins
and their associated light chains
i like this slide because it gives a
buffs a snapshot as to multiple myeloma
when you look at the green line on the
on the slide here and the graph we can
see the
rate of diagnosis of new cases of
multiple myeloma
in and around 2003 we can kind of see a
sharp increase to the new cases of
multiple
myeloma that arise
and i attribute this increase to the
better technology that we have at
picking up these patients
in addition we see the death rate at
death rate
associated with multiple myeloma in the
uh
black triangles
and again at around the same time period
of around 2003 2004 we see also a
decrease in the death rate that i tr and
i attribute that to the better
medicine that we have at treating these
patients with multiple myeloma
overall
the better laboratory
criteria diagnosis as well as the better
treatment options result in a 77.5
survival five-year survival rate
now multiple myeloma presents with
relatively vague symptoms
typically can present as back pain and
unfortunately all of us today have been
experiencing back pain by sitting in our
chairs for extended periods of time
also can experience patients can
experience bone pain as well as fatigue
as a patient presents to the
to the physician that these non-specific
symptoms
if the clinical presentation is
consistent with that of a plasma cell
dyskrazia in this case a multiple
myeloma type of picture
the physician is able to do additional
tests
one to measure organ damage the
traditional laboratory evaluations for
measuring organ damage in the context of
multiple myeloma are defined by the
pneumonic crab which indicates
calcium elevations or hypercalcemia
renal dysfunction anemia as well as bone
nations
in addition
the m proteins quantified by various
techniques one we can measure intact
immunoglobulins
or we can measure free light genes
there's additional assays such as serum
protein
electrophoresis and serum immuno
fixation
as well as urine protein
electrophoresis and urine immuno
fixation and finally we can measure the
serum free light chain ratio which is a
topic of today's talk
in addition there are a number of other
biomarkers which now formed another
mnemonic that's commonly being used is
the slim crab criteria where the slim
represents 60
or greater
bone marrow plasma cells plus a light
chain ratio greater than or equal to 100
and lesions found by an mri being
greater than one
and i'll talk about specifically that
light chain ratio of greater than or
equal to 100 in the coming presentation
when we look at the progression of or
the disease progression of multiple
myeloma it's really broken up into three
distinct categories one is monoclonal
demography of undetermined significance
or emgas typically does not present with
any n-organ damage is non-asymptomatic
and typically it's a pre-malignant stage
of multiple myeloma
unfortunately one percent of patients
progress per year to multiple myeloma
after being diagnosed with mgus
the intermediate category as i like to
call it is smoldering myeloma and in
this particular case again there's no
end organ damage patients are
non-asymptomatic and about 10 of those
patients progress within five years to
multiple myeloma
and finally multiple myeloma the
presence typically the patients present
with some type of end organ failure two
of the three are required
typically again the patients are
symptomatic and they have a mean
survival of about five years and i can i
alluded to about the 77.5
immune survival rate at five years
but what is a common thread for these
particular patients
it's really our ability to monitor
disease progression in these different
disease states patients going from
mgus to smoldering myeloma to finally
multiple myeloma
but what's important about these
monoclonal democracies is how to
properly assess these patients
this pa this paper looked at different
screening algorithms associated with
monochroma democracies
and i like this paper even though it's
published in 2009 what it does it really
highlights the importance of having
adequate and appropriate screening
processes in in place in your laboratory
here we have different diagnostic
estates looking at multiple myeloma
macroglobulinemia
smoldering myeloma mgus
and and primary
amyloidosis what we see is if we take
multiple myeloma as an example out of
the 467 patients that were analyzed when
using appropriate screening algorithms
for example using cm protein
electrophoresis gaining a fixation and
free leg chain
100 of the patients were able to be
adequately diagnosed
on the other hand for example looking at
mgus
about 524 patients were analyzed
and when you again
apply appropriate uh screening
algorithms you can get more than 90 of
those patients adequately tested and
diagnosed when looking at using
appropriate screening protocols
but before we start talking about
specifically freight light chains let's
kind of re-baseline everybody we know
that serum protein metropolis also known
as ms pep is an easy inexpensive method
of separating proteins based on their
charge size and shape
the two major types of proteins present
in the serum are albumin
and globulin proteins
now albumin is the major protein
component of serum and represents the
largest peak that lies closest to the
positive electrode
globulins make up a much smaller
fraction of the total serum protein but
represent the primary focus of
interpretation of serum protein
electrophoresis
five globulin categories are represented
alpha one
alpha two
beta one beta two and gamma with the
gamma fraction
being the closest to the negative
electrode and again this is what
indicates the diagnosis or the
characterization of the m spike
now when we look at the slide when we
look at the
the electrophoretic mobility what we
notice is that we have a normal
distribution of the different fractions
we can see we have a normal albumin peak
and of course the other four fractions
are within normal ranges i also want to
point out that it's also important to
make sure that the specimen quality for
serum protein interfaces is appropriate
and that an adequate cm specimen is
being used
we as a kind of again refresher serum is
devoid of any of the coagulation
proteins whereas plasma maintains the
coagulation proteins as a former lab
director what i've noticed in the past
is i have seen what's called beta gamma
bridging sometimes you can get a bridge
between the beta and the gamma which may
indicate the presence of fibrinogen or
inadequate inadequately coagulated
specimen
however when we do get a proper specimen
and we do run
the serum protein
what we do see is that if we see an m
spike present much like we see in the
slide just now
this denotes one that there is an m
spike two we can quantitate it by doing
densiometry but the third thing that we
need to do is we need to categorize that
in order for us to properly categorize
the m spike we need to do immunofixation
techniques this is just an example of
different types of
immunoglobulin characterizations that we
see
for example you can see that the one
patient may have an igg kappa which is
noted in the very middle panel you can
see the nice bands that are associated
with the gamma spike
m spike excuse me plus the igg kappa
that's seen
now this is important to categorize
these uh these monochrome these
monoclonal dermatitis in order to
properly treat these patients
now there are two types of free light
genes there's free light chain kappa and
free light chain lambda
now kappa free lychees circulate as
monomers of 25 kilodons while
lambda-free light chains are usually
present in dimers of 59 kilodons
as small proteins free lychees are
freely filtered by the kidney the
smaller feed light chain kappa complexes
slightly more efficiently than the
larger free light seen lambda molecules
resulting in a half lifetime of about
two to three hours for free light chain
kappa and about four to six hours for
free light you need lambda
the short half lifetime is important for
monitoring the therapy response in
monochroma gammopathies as the complete
immunoglobulin
globulin complex shows a much longer
half-life
for example the shortest is igg adiron
at around three weeks
now like other small proteins like
sustain c for example or alpha one
microglobulin
the light chains are reabsorbed from
urine by renal tubules
when the reabsorption capacity is maxed
out three light chains are excreted in
the urine resulting in a overflow
protein area also known as benz jones
proteinuria and this is where urine
immunity fixation may play a significant
role
now for healthy individuals
concentrations of free lychees are
relatively low
and there are equal concentrations of
both types of light cells
it is normal for the concentration of
both tests to increase when immune
system is for example stimulated if a
patient has a chronic inflammation or as
a chronic infection or has an autoimmune
disease great light chain ratios may be
elevated
on the contrary there is a decrease is
observed when patients experience some
type of renal dysfunction i always want
i also want to point out
that the reference ranges for these
normal capital minor ratios may change
depending on the assays being used
unequal concentrations of free light
chain kappa and lambda either through
kappa overproduction or lambda
overproduction result in abnormally high
or low free lambda
free capital lambda ratios
now this is an indication of a plasma
cell disorder such as a
monochromatinopathy
but i also want to point out the
importance of what i refer to as the
involved free light chains for example
if we have an elevated capital lambda
ratio the involved free lag chain in
this case would be kappa whereas the
uninvolved would be lambda on the other
hand if we have a low free kappa free
capital lambda ratio the involved
freelancing
is the lambda where the uninvolved is
kappa and i want to point out this is
important especially when interpreting
these results for kappa and lambda
ratios
i really like this slide because it
really highlights the importance of why
free lighting intestine is more
sensitive than detecting myeloma
so just imagine that we have a fresh
basket of oranges
in a situation in which a patient is
presenting an early stage myeloma which
is mgus for example
if i measure impact immunoglobulins in
the context of these basque of fresh
oranges
can i really tell whether or not there
is an
excess amount of oranges when i'm
looking at the basket as a whole
i i the answer to that question is no
because you really can't tell whether
one or two or even three oranges have it
placed in that buck in that basket of
fresh oranges
where the free light chain this is where
it distinguishes itself is that for
example
instead of measuring the whole orange
you imagine a piece or a slice of that
orange
for example in a healthy patient we have
two slices as an example as the patient
begins to progress and is it is in this
m gus stage
instead of having two slices now we have
four there's an effective doubling of
the number of slices
this allows you to have a better picture
as to the state patient's status
now in detecting free light genes
freelance for each patient has a unique
is unique in its variable region as they
noted here in the slide
however the constant region for this
free light change assay are identical
from patient to patient
in addition different and different
vendors may use different methods to
prepare the antibodies for example
there's a polyclonal antiserial that can
be used as well as multiclonal
antibodies that can be used for to help
distinguish or
pick up these free leg chains
now this slide just looks at three of
the more the vendors that have uh
free light chain as is available
and these asks and these vendors for
example one is binding set which has
been in the market for a number of years
now
is has the free light assay
and it's typical and it's a polyglonal
assay
siemens has an n latex freely chain
assay and it's monoclonal and there's a
third company by the name of diazine
which has another human free light chain
acid available and again it's a
polyclonal assay so remember these are
two tests looking at free lambda kappa
and free lambda three left free lambda
and we're looking at three numbers
kappa the lambda and the capital lambda
ratio i also just a point of
clarification on this slide i've denoted
where the antibodies bind but this is
just for illustrative purposes is it
done to note that the end latex acid
binds to the constant region whereas the
free light
binds to the variable region again this
is just strictly for illustrative
purposes
now the end litex assay has because is
fda approved and it's approved for the
aid in the diagnosis of multiple myeloma
al amyloidosis as well as mds
again it's a multi-monocular antibody
that's used for to detect free lambda
and free kappa it's comparable to the
free light assay
in addition
it has overall good lot to lock
consistency
and it avoids fall positive positives in
patients with female dysfunction
however it's really important that you
interpret the data in a stepwise fashion
number one we should always interpret
any type of free light chain data
together with the complete clinical
picture that is we take every all the
data that we have the laboratory data
which can include your calcium your
creatinine your immunity of your your
hemoglobin for example your serum
protein interfaces and your ups all the
laboratory data plus the imaging results
plus the clinical presentation of the of
the patient to interpret the free
lighting data appropriately
looking at the cap on lambda
if you have a high capital lambda ratio
that strongly in indicates that the
involved ratio an involved light chain
in this case is the capital
if you have a low capital lambda ratio
this indicates that the involved free
lychee in this case is lambda
you also want to verify the results by
looking at the involved elevation if
there's no elevation then there is no
evidence for a monoclonal light sheen by
this method
you also want to look at the uninvolved
if low then may that may explain that
the abnormal ratio
is without evidence of a monoclonal
nitrate so it's really important to look
at this in a stepwise fashion
so when we look at the end latex assay
it recently has been given fda
a clearance for mgus front m-gus claim
and this is just a snippet from the
intended intended use of the from from
the instructions produced for the mitex
assay
now
it's really as an aid in the evaluation
of monoclonal gammopaphy of undetermined
significance
i allow it to use it can be used on the
bn system as well as anatelica ch
analyzers but remember the results of
any type of free light chain measurement
should always be interpreted in
conjunction with other laboratory as
well as other clinical findings
now in this study conducted by granite
colleagues
using the siemens health and ears and
latex assay they showed for example in
panel a that there was no significant
difference in the time to progression in
the group that had measurable disease by
step and in if involved three light
genes
and panel b
in patients who had measurable disease
by s pep only the progression was
observed significantly earlier with
aspep compared to that of iflc
however iflc detected progression
significantly earlier that is at the
19.6 months time frame compared to the
urine protein which resists which
detected at 63.7 months
in the group with measurable disease by
up and iflc alone
now this study really just highlights
the importance of monitoring or
measuring the involve free light chain
assays when compared to aspects
especially in patients with progression
more than 18 months after best response
to therapy
now the upper curve illustrates the risk
of progression of monoclonal demography
of undetermined significance in patients
with an abnormal serum capital lambda
ratio again in this particular case
we're using 0.26 to 1.65
again depending on which assay one uses
those ratios may in fact change
and what this basically shows is that
those that had an abnormal free light
chain ratio had more had progressed to
multiple myeloma
and i really like this particular slide
or figure excuse me that shows
that depending on which side of
the ratio you fall on there is an
increased relative risk to progression
to multiple myeloma so the more abnormal
your ratio is the higher risk of
progression and again using that .26 to
1.65 ratios here
monochromatimophy of undetermined
significance is a premalignant clonal
plasma cell disorder as we've already
described with a one percent relative
risk of progression to multiple myeloma
now
certain risk factors determine the
likelihood of progression from mgus and
smoldering myeloma to multiple myeloma
for example an m spike of greater than
1.5 grams per deciliter you have being
over the age of 65 and having an
involve-free light chain of more than
100 milligrams per liter
now these risk factors help physicians
determine who is likely to progress to
multiple myeloma
diagnose them early and find out which
patients need to be treated early
now this study that was conducted by the
international myeloma working group
carried out using the end latex free
light chain assay and found that
patients with none of these risk factors
have a two percent five-year cumulative
probability of progression to multiple
myeloma
whereas patients with two or three of
these risk factors have a 31 5-year
cumulative probability of progression to
multiple myeloma
this was essentially verified in another
study that was connected again by grant
which showed again in those patients
that progressed to multiple myeloma as
indicated in the teal color
those patients had a higher or had more
of these risk factors
compared to those patients that did not
progress to what
with amda that did not progress to
multiple myeloma again seeing the m
protein greater than 1.5 and the inevol
free lychee greater than 100 milligrams
per liter
an increased involved free lysine
greater than 100 milligrams per liter
from
show here where we can see that again
the risk factors here
any of these risk factors greater than
100
uh an m spike greater than 1.5 or 65
years of age or older these patients
more than the more risk factors one
patient has the more relative risk of
progression to multiple multiple myeloma
there is this is nicely illustrated by
this figure here which shows
the number of risk factors and here if
any if you have two or more risk factors
in that kind of
grade outline the risk of progression is
significantly more elevated
so this this this study did a nice
comparison by just looking at the m
protein versus the involved free light
chain
i just want to what why i want to focus
on the baseline values first before we
go to the end time
so baseline means at any point at the
baseline belt if the patient had m
protein that was greater than 0.5 grams
per deciliter increase
the risk of progression is highlighted
in the black line
and the shaded region essentially means
the 95 confidence interval but you can
see that around the 50-month time frame
the after
follow-up you can see that the risk of
progression is around one to three
percent
however
if the patient
had an increase greater than 100
milligrams per deciliter at baseline if
the eye involved free lysing was
elevated greater than that 100 threshold
you see that the relative risk of
progression increased dramatically to
about six to seven percent even over
that 15-month time period
indicating that info-free lychee may be
a better marker at picking up patients
that progress to multiple myeloma
any time is at any time during the
course of the follow-up
if the m protein was greater than 0.5
grams per deciliter increase you can see
the risk for effort that progression
actually decreased as
as longer as the follow was longer so
for example at the 20 versus the 50
month time frame you can see there's a
significant decrease
however with the involved free light
chains you can see that there's an
increase in the progression or risk of
progression to to multiple myeloma as
shown again in the trigger in figure or
panel d
so this study that was done by lang lang
land green
showed that in panel c for example those
patients that progressed to multiple
myeloma or that did not progress excuse
me did not exceed the 100 milligrams per
liter you can nicely see that the trend
line which is indicated in in orange
shows that these patients did not exceed
that 100 milligram per liter threshold
on the other hand
those patients with embryos that
progress to multiple myeloma you can see
that there's a much wider variation in
their in their uh involved light chain
concentration and the trend line again
the orange line shows a significant
increase
indicating again that the involve free
light chain may be giving useful
information as to the progression of
disease or progression to multiple
myeloma in these patients without death
a revised diagnostic criteria that was
proposed
aimed to accurately identify high risk
and ultra high risk smoldering myeloma
patients
now the revised definition known as the
rule 100 and i alluded to this in the
beginning slides
included clonal bone marrow plasma cells
are equal to or more than 10
and one or more of the following myeloma
defining events that is clonal bone
marrow plasma cell percentage of equal
to or more than sixty percent
and involved to uninvolve serum light
chain ratio equal to or more than one
hundred and more than one focal lesion
in on mri studies this has helped to
define or determine which smoldering
roma patient are most at risk of
progression to multiple myeloma and who
will therefore need further treatment
in a 2019 study done by henrot and
colleagues it found that both the
freelay and the n-latex acids can be
used to accurately identify
high risk and ultra high risk smoldering
myeloma patients when using the rule 100
criteria
however helm henriette also concluded
that the enlight act and latex assay
could also be used for smoldering
myeloma patient monitoring like the free
light and that the end latex serum free
light chain ratio of greater than or 70
appear to provide similar performance to
a freelance freelance chain ratio of
greater than or equal to 100 with a
slightly better positive predictive
value
so smoldering myeloma is a plasma cell
disorder as already described as that
intermediate category of multiple
myeloma with disease progression with a
10 year risk of progression to multiple
myeloma
so in 2020 the international myeloma
working group or imwg
took it upon themselves to develop a
risk stratification model to identify
these smoldering myeloma patients which
were at high risk of progressing to
multiple myeloma or some other plasma
cell disorder
and what they did is they looked at four
independent factors and they developed
this 2 20 20 risk stratification model
it looked at one serum protein spikes or
m spikes greater than two grams per
deciliter
involved uninvolved free light chain
ratio of greater than 20
and narrow involvement
of greater than 20
and the fourth criteria was looking at
cytogenetic abnormalities and they
assessed how these patients progressed
to multiple myeloma
and one it helped identify these high
risk patients better and as widely
applicable
now this graph shows that using the 20
20 20 model with three risk factors
allows to determine within the first two
years from diagnosis
the likelihood of patients progressing
from smoldering myeloma to that of
multiple myeloma
we see that smoldering myeloma patients
with no risk factors have a six percent
chance of progressing to multiple
myeloma
while those with one risk factor have an
18 chance
and those with two or three risk factors
have a 44 chance
this second graph shows that including
cytogenetic abnormalities in the risk
stratification model means a group of
patients who are at even higher risk of
disease progression can be identified
earlier
we see that those patients with three or
more risk factors
including those of cytogenetic
abnormalities
are categorized as high risk and have a
63 percent 63 percent chance of
progressing to multiple myeloma two
years after diagnosis
now that's all great about the
laboratory diagnostics but what do we
really measure and all these models that
are currently being used but how do we
really take that into con into practical
use well for example the imwg guidelines
look that says well if your patients
have low risk that is they have a normal
fluid light chain ratio your m spike is
less than 1.5
and it has an isotype of an igg for
example it requires infrequent
monitoring
well if your patient then becomes
high or intermediate risk where your
free light chain ratio becomes abnormal
german spike is greater than 1.5 then
perhaps a more recent or more
recent our
monitoring system is recommended
grand study looked at it slightly
differently and he categorized it again
into three the patients in the three
groups low intermediate and high where
instead of having
uh you know
uh broad or long
times between monitoring suggesting that
the patient should be monitored let's
say every six months for mgus
if the patients are a higher risk
perhaps a three-month interval is
recommended
so there's a lot of work and a lot of
discussion going on which is the
appropriate risk stratification model
for patients of mgus to decide what and
to see how they progress and if these
progress patients progress to multiple
myeloma because as i talk as i said
earlier the importance of free light
generation is perhaps the ability to
diagnose these patients earlier and
being able to treat them more
effectively
so in conclusion
we know that multiple myeloma is a
cancer of the plasma cells again
reiterating that basically the plasma
cells go haywire producing all sorts of
immune goblins primarily of one specific
isotype a one associated with a specific
free light chain
free light chain acids are important in
monitoring and glass progression as i
hope i've been able to convince you that
looking at these free light chains
either as the involved or the free light
chain ratio there are good markers at
monitoring the progression of i'm gus to
perhaps multiple myeloma
but there is one problem there's a lack
of standardization and it's important to
know which assay is being used
for example if one fund if one hospital
system is changing from one to the other
it's really important and really
critical that proper communication is
done
commissions are in form of a change you
need to really think about re-baselining
your patients because really free light
shines are in fact tumor markers
and it's good to read based on because
reference ranges will change
ratios may change so it's good to
re-establish that baseline when a new
message is implemented in your
laboratory
and finally it's always important to
interpret the data in correlation with
the clinical picture
your laboratory data provides the
necessary information for you that for
the patient and the clinician to make
the diagnosis but it has to be
interpreted within the overall clinical
context we as laboratorians are able to
provide the necessary tools and the
information the clinician and the
clinician takes those tools and puts
that piece of the puzzle together to
provide and to have an accurate
diagnosis
and with that i'd like to thank everyone
for your attention and i will turn it
back to dr lenz for any for any
questions thank you
thank you dr mitchell's
that very informative
and thoughtful presentation
appreciate that in a moment we're going
to start the live q a portion of the
webinar
so if you have a question you'd like to
ask i invite you to please do so now
there is an ask a question tile located
on the far left side of the screen
we will answer as many questions as we
have time for
before we begin
which wouldn't mind we invite you to
participate in a series of poll
questions
and they start here
are you currently involved in research a
clinical diagnosis of mgus
multiple myeloma or al amyloidosis yes
or no
moving on to the next
question
are you currently running free light
chain in your lab essay menu yes or no
and lastly
would you be interested in potentially
participating as a speaker in future
webinars with us
yes or no and if yes
could you please provide your name and
contact information
on
this uh slide here
well thank you for that participation
let's go ahead and continue with our
live question and answer session
dr mitchell is glad to have you here
i have a few questions
that have come into the queue
so if you'd like let's get started
when
the first question is when changing
instrument vendors
uh could you please help me the person
understand
how that process occurs
and then again what about the need for
for rebaselining patients in your
opinion
sure can you guys hear me
very well
all right so with any validation of any
instrumentation or new information that
comes from the laboratory typically
laboratories have their own validation
setting cards that they follow um
oftentimes there's guidance that comes
from the
vendor of choice um
guiding the lab to validate their
instrumentation so
typically a standard validation protocol
will be
you know precision studies correlation
studies and of course uh reference
training studies just in a few and it's
interesting that you brought the lead
baselining question up um
you know with with multiple myeloma or
am gus the three light chains are really
uh essentially through my mercury's
and when changing from one number to
another you automatically have to be
based on these patients because you can
imagine
different uh systems operate slightly
differently so you really need to be
able to assess these activities as an
essentially based on their patients with
the new asset that you bring in house
before that answers uh your question
that's great and to the individual that
posted that question
uh if if that was not sufficient please
let us know but thank you for that
answer
uh next question dr mutzios a person
works in the field of nephrology
and is interested
in your comments on
elevated free-like pain in patients with
chronic kidney disease could you comment
on that please
sure this is actually a very good
question um and really i think the
question can be broken down or the
answer the question can be broken under
so essentially two cards
one we kind of focus a little bit about
anti-design antibody design and two it's
the formalization of the free light
genes
so when you look at um you know these
patients with chronic kidney disease um
some studies have shown
that these patients may have may develop
high order structures
like for example diameters and timers
so specifically uh kappa chains are more
susceptible to these higher order
structures so in patients with chronic
kidney disease they're being increased
in these high horrible structures
therefore if you're an antibody designed
to pick up those let's say higher
structures you may have a slightly more
of an elevated uh for example capital
omb ratio
so if your asset will say it's able not
only to detect those monomers but it can
also protect these dimers and trimmers
it may result in a false elevation and
tap off while your alarm directors
remain same there's that beginning an
elevated voice of perhaps
misinterpreting or assuming the results
are going to produce results in
different directions
on the other hand if you're
antibiotically detect only the monomers
then both for example you're free and
cat street kappa and kernel lambda would
be elevated while your ratio essentially
remains the same indicating that there
isn't really an involved
hopefully that answers your question
that was thorough and again
through all the individuals posting the
questions if the answer is not
sufficient please let us know
um great questions coming in uh here's
another one for you
uh are there other conditions in which
uh flc measurements
might be of benefit you touched on a
little here but maybe if you could
elaborate more please
sure so free light chain markers are
obviously important in modern
connections with you know mgus or
multiple normal so it's really important
in these type of
disorders so really it's important to
use plasma cell proliferative disorders
so they can be used for monitoring
disease progression and treatments
in addition to that they can also be
used in other business things like
amyloidosis and nitrogen depositions
disease just an msu
excellent thank you for that
answer and again
for anyone that wants to ask questions
there is an ask question pile on the far
left side of the screen
uh there are a few more here in the
queue that i'd like to get to
uh another question documents you know
she might have covered this and and i
might have missed it personally it's
maybe being a little late
what is the role of electrophoresis in
mgu's evaluation
and and then there's a follow-up
question and and what about serum
immunofixation
well when you look at sampropolis
research it's really used to identify
serum protein dissolves which obviously
includes multiple myeloma and patients
who have gus
now
set s peps or serum protonators can be
used as really a screening uh an initial
evaluation for a number of clinical
conditions
it can be used for example in
unexplained peripheral neuropathy
uh it could be obviously
associated with uh assessing patients
who have suspected multiple myeloma or
even patients who have a new onset of
back pain and viscosity of failure all
of which lead the clinician to put you
know order osteoporosis to be able to
see is there elevation in these
particular protein fractions
so in addition to what i mentioned kind
of above
the you know
the s cup also provides additional
information as to the patient's clinical
status now for example if there's an
increase in let's say the alden
infection that very first fraction of
come off comes off the same protein
this may be an indication the creation
is dehydrated so it could falsely uh
missing the initiative with those
results for example
increasing the gamma fraction may
indicate a variety of clinical
conditions like amyloidosis plant
infections cirrhosis
and malignant lymphoma and of course
multiple myeloma
now on the other hand
the indifferentiation was the
characterization of the gamma fractions
fight
so it allows us to assess whether or not
the visualizing igg
lambda or igg kappa
and and it allows the physician
physician to then categorize it and go
to monitor that that
fraction
but again it's always important to
interpret the results within the
appropriate clinical context so
taking that those results
along with the clinical presentation
this complication to determine
the diagnosis
excellent
thank you for the very thorough complete
answer appreciate that we're going to
switch
slightly topics
get away from free light chain promo and
although there's a few more questions
on that topic next question for you dr
mitchell what does a typical lab
protocol look like for validation
so i we kind of already covered that and
i think it was really the first question
i was asked but basically again it's
really looking at
you know precision studies making sure
that the studies are according to the
internal
correlation studies there's reference
ranges
limited detection and obviously the list
is endless but again it's working hand
in hand with your vendor of choice to be
able to come up with a validation
protocol that fits into the privacy of
the institution
excellent and and there's one more
question
before we wrap up if you have a few more
minutes if anyone wants to get a
last-minute question
like the last one i have in front of me
here is uh this individual often has uh
discussions with people in the field
about the measure merits of measuring
uh just kappa and lambda
versus those also uh looking at the
ratio as you alluded to
early in your talk can you give uh some
more thoughts on that please
well i again i think it really has to do
with looking at the
entire or a clinical picture which also
includes the laboratory data so just
measuring free lab and free from kappa
provides useful clinical information but
you also have to take them through the
appropriate chemical context
so you know take into consideration the
involved or the uninvolved light chains
you know mainly the definition to either
the appropriate diagnosis or the
appropriate treatment protocol that
would be sufficient for this particular
patient so again it's looking at the
entire constellation of symptoms plus
the laboratory data from facility and
accurate diagnosis and again ultimately
improved patient care which i think they
are all in the business of doing so hope
that answers the question
very good thank you
so
as we wrap up i'd like to
again thank dr mithios one more time for
your your time today uh very insightful
uh understanding expertise on the
subject
i would also we would love to thank lab
roots
our sponsors of this webinar today
as well as siemens health and ears for
underwriting today's educational webcast
and before we go i'd like to thank you
the audience for your time and attention
today
and your interest
if you have further questions or
conversations that you would like to
have
dr mitchios's contact information is in
the screen here
be more than happy to reach out and have
a conversation with you additionally he
will be attending aacec this year
in chicago at the end of july and he
will be located in booth
2013.
lastly
as most of you probably assume this
webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing
lab roots will provide an alert via
email when it's available for replay and
so we encourage you to
look at the video and share that email
with your colleagues who might have
missed today's event so with that i'd
like to thank you for your time and
attention and wish you a wonderful rest
of your day
you